校長がさっきおっしゃってた信頼できる
人間の3条件っていうのを伺いたい
です本能が完璧これは信用できるんだだ
から本能を完璧にするためにどうする
正しい行動を繰り返せば本能が完璧になる
公然の気を養うって書いてあるんだから
それを信じて正しいことをざとするように
すりゃええということは文化はだめやねこ
しないもんね結果出さんでええんやから
正しい行動っていうのは結果が出るんや
からねだから結果出さんでいい文化系って
いうのは信用ならんはないそれから大会系
これは信用なるよね正しい行動をするため
に体育会系やっとるんだからから現場の
人間仕事は正しい結果出さんといかんのや
から正しい行動しとるわねだ全部申しの
言う義を行っとるんだだから大会系か理科
系か現場かこの3つが揃うほど信用できる
ということや
ね逆に言うとその3つがない人はちょっと
信用しにくいっていう嘘言うからね例えば
その3つがそれぞれ逆ってどういう人なん
ですかね現場主義じゃなくて現場じゃない
事務所の人間それから大会経者なしにま
あれを文化系っていうのかなそれから理科
刑者なしに文化系そういうのは喋っとって
も親用ならんじゃんこいつ本当のこと言っ
とるんかなという気がする褒められたらあ
こいつベンチャ言っとるなと思うじゃん
テレビの評論家とか官僚とかそういう
イメージですか例えばね野球評論家という
のは元野球選手じゃんうんうんだから信用
してもええんだはいもう自分が実際にやっ
とるからねはい相撲でもあれでも大会系の
評論家というのは信用できるやろはいだ
けど社会評論家なんか信用ならんやないか
経済評論家自分が儲けれゃええやないか
なんで自分が儲かるのに人に教えるんや嘘
やなと思った方がええそれで言うと小ママ
さんって一応現場主義ではあるですよね
あれリベラルだからダメなんじゃああそっ
かリベラルでやったら間違いやろも教員
組合のね日教祖の人間やろ日教祖が間違っ
とったから教育がこうなったわけであって
教育をダメにした人間の言うこと聞いても
ええのか結果が出とるじゃんだめという
リベラルは文化系なんですか文化系理科系
にもおるけどな驚いたことには自民党の中
にもリベラルおるよね分かってないんだ
みんなねリベラルが正しいと思っとる
マスコミだからもうちょっとな自分の言っ
てることをよく分かろうよ自分の言ってる
こと分かってないやろ
みんなうちなんかよく文句言ってくるやつ
権利を守れうん分かった守るけど権利って
何なのたらさあそれはて言い出すやろ
こんなことで文句言ってくんなこれこれれ
こうしろと言ってく来るんやったらええよ
具体的に権利とはこうだからこうしろと
そうやねただ権利という言葉を使って最も
無責任はあの自由自由とはなんか知らずに
自由だて言い出すやろあれがいかんよ哲学
所なんか呼んでみてくらんヨーロッパの話
よ我々は自由の経に処せられているって
書いてあるわ自由となんか分からずにお前
自由だと言われたってどうしていいか
わからんやろはっきりと自由とはこうだと
いうことを定義してからお前は自由になれ
だよ自由っていうのは作るもんだから自由
になれそれやったらええだけど自由の意味
も知らずに自由だ自由だと言ったのが今の
風潮やない
か1点コメント欄の反論で校長哲学とか
宗教とかは答えがいくつもあるから間違っ
てるっていうお話されてたじゃないですか
ま仏教は宗教もしくは哲学じゃないかって
いう反論がありました仏教は科学ですよ
呼んでみてくらんちゃんと理系が読むと
仏教は科学なんだだから内容をよく分から
ずに決めるからいかんのだ偉い人が仏教は
宗教だと言うからなだけど元々はね単なる
教えやったんだ仏教というのは仏の教え
ないそれが教えは儲からんのだおせが来
ないからだから宗教にして金儲けしたいん
や途中でで宗教になっただけどもっと宗教
らしいインドは今早とのは何やったあれに
やられとるじゃあっちは完璧な宗教やもん
自分でやれというのが仏教だからね神様が
助けてくれるというのが宗教やからねこれ
宗教のね流るに決まっとるじゃんみんな
正月に100円のお賽銭あれして長いこと
お祈りしとるやないなあ図々しくないあれ
が宗教なんだ神様がいないものは宗教じゃ
ない自分を助けるてくれる神様がいるのが
宗教な仏教はいない自分で自分を助けろと
いうのが仏教
今日本だと釈迦が神様みたいに扱われてる
と思うんですけどいや途中から宗教になっ
たからさ釈迦如来やもんねだけど如来の
意味は知らんやろパリ語でタガっていうて
そいつを見てこらパリオ時点でも買ってそ
したら神様じゃないことが分かる元に帰ら
ずに教わったことをそのまま正しいと信じ
てやるもんでおかしなことになっちゃう
えっとね私の言うことは正しいことりだだ
から今からまだ続くから
え正しい
人生死ぬ時に満足の行く人生それを送り
たけれ
ばチャンネル登録してずっと聞いてくれ